ça veut dire que Johnny avait un côté
féminin tous les hommes artistes ont des
simplement Johnny parce qu'il faut avoir
des des des qualités masculines pour une
femme quand quand on fait ce métier
inversement des qualités féminines quand
on est un homme et donc de voir
quelqu'un se poudrait le nez à 50 ans
moi je peux
pas je suis très contente que vous soyez
là oui ça faisait longtemps pr rendez-v
et oui et oui alors on vous décrit
Sylvie varan comme quelqu'un de
trèspudique retenu qui cache ses
émotions je suis très émotive mais
disons qu'en public je j'essaie de ne
pas le montrer trop je suis très double
alors double hardi sur scène oui je n'ai
absolument oui aucune pudeur je peux
faire n'importe quoi si je suis dans un
contexte de jeu et de où j'ai un alibi
en fait mais quand je suis moi-même dans
la vie je suis quelqu'un de de pudique
oui mais je suis comme on m'a appris à
être en fait c'est-à-dire parce que que
ma maman était comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on m'a montré la route et alors ce
que vous dites he surtout dans le livre
qui paraît maintenant aux édition xxo
dans la lumière c'est que c'était une
époque où c'est ce que l'on disait la
vie privée n'existait pas ù se conjugait
avec cétait malgré malgré moi à vrai
dire parce qu'on a c'était ce moment
c'était tellement nouveau c'était une
vraie révolution aussi bien social que
culturel et c'était la première fois que
des des gamins parce que c'est ce qu'on
était euh prenait une sorte de de de
pouvoir un ascendant sur les euh sur un
public que tout un public jeune se
retrouvait en en nous et euh et c'est
vrai que la musique a été le véhicule de
tout ça et donc subitement euh on on
faisait la une des journaux euh euh sans
arrêt mais on inventait des histoires
même on avait après petit à petit au fil
des années il y avait des attachés de
presse aussi qui euh qui alimenta tout
ça même sans sans qu'on le sache hein et
avec le sentiment quand vous avez aussi
vous dites volé pratiquement toute votre
histoire avec Johnny votre mariage qui
ressemblit à une kermesse dit c'était
d'ailleurs curieusement quand maintenant
avec le recul quand je regarde ces
images c'est d'une violence extrême en
fait parce que ça ça ça fait peur il y
avait des photographes cachés partout et
c'est vrai que c'était terrible jamais
aucune intimité non puis on s'en
habituit quelque part parce qu' on
pouvait absolument pas lutter donc on
s'en habituait on vivait avec voilà
c'est bien que les premières fois que
j'allais aux États-Unis et que personne
ne me connaissait je me disais mais
c'est incroyable c'est le paradis en
fait de ne pas être regarder de d'avoir
cette possibilité de d'être léger comme
ça c'est ce que je voulais vous demander
parce que ici quand on dit Sylvie Vartan
ici on pense Johnny Hidé on dit souvent
Sylvie Johnny donc ça vous amuse ça vous
énerve vous dites c'est hallucinant ce
non ça ne m'énerve pas dans la mesure où
ça existait et que c'est vrai que ça a
existé pour beaucoup et et bon quand je
regarde ces images c'est vrai qu'on
était comme deux enfants on allait bien
ensemble on faisait le même métier c'est
vrai que on comprend bien
pourquoi il y avait un engouement par
rapport à à notre couple alors on entend
Bernard fixo je disais votre ami depuis
30 ans dire quand sylvie a rencontré
Tony Scotty c'était enfin voilà la vie
lui paraissait possible oui c'est vrai
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
parce que j'étais toujours très seule
j'ai jamais été épaulé évidemment j'ai
ma famille mais ma famille était en
dehors de ce tourbillon mais il
n'empêche que dans ma vie de femme
j'étais j'étais très seu toujours très
seu donc euh moi j'avais j'avais besoin
de euh d'un rêve enfin je je rêvais un
homme parfait comme comme on m'avait
appris que les hommes devaient être
c'est-à-dire quel sont les qu protect
rigolo
sensible il est comme ça il est comme ça
ça ou oui la chance j'ai une chance
j'ose pas trop le dire parce que non non
d'ailleurs dans dans votre livre hein
vous dites que votre chance a été qu'il
ne vous connaissent pas qu'il ne
sacheent pas que vous étiez une vedette
française si oui c'est un grand handicap
d'être très connu parce qu'il y a des
hommes et souvent les hommes assez
intéressant ne vont pas aller s'afficher
avec quelqu'un très connu ça c'est vrai
c'est ce que vous avez vécu moi je pense
oui bah vous les faites
fuirin la la
vérité ceux qui qui aiment les
paillettes qui qui veulent se payer un
trophée qui veulent qu'on parle d'eux
faire
REM une aventure ou même qui ont besoin
d'être connu et de d'être reconnu tout
ça c'est vrai que d'épouser quelqu'un de
célèbre et bien c'est vrai que ça aide
mais quand on les avez tenu au loin ceux
vous les avez repéré je
repère j'ai acquis oui oui une faculté
oui de repérer les Gensel qu'ils sont
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé très jeune
je suis un peu comme Terminator je je
regarde le laser PAF la carte je sais
exactement vous êtes pas trompé non mes
premières impressions sont toujours les
bonnes d'ailleurs vous dites à 35 ans
donc vous aviez quitté Johnny vous étiez
déjà séparé à 35 ans sur le plan
sentimental la vie ne me paraît pas très
prometteuse non jugeter sur mon
piédestal de star je ne vois pas très
bien quel homme je pourrais rencontrer à
part mon double c'est-à-dire un artiste
traversé par les mêmes fellures les
mêmes folies et là merci j'ai déjà donné
oui c'est-à-dire que je me disais
comment vais-je trouver quelqu'un qui
comprenne ce que je fais mes émotions
mes besoins ce métier s'il est par
exemple dans une branche totalement
différente c'est impossible il faut
quelqu'un d'artistique en même temps or
les hommes artistes ils ont un côté trop
féminin pour moi moi j'ai besoin d'être
une vraie femme dire et ça veut dire que
Johnny avait un côté féminin les hommes
artistes ont des pas simplement j parce
qu'il faut avoir des des des qualités
masculines pour une femme quand quand on
fait ce métier inversement des qualités
féminines quand on est un homme et donc
de voir quelqu'un se poudraer le nez à
50 ans moi je peux pas ah c'est ça je me
dis mais qu'est-ce qu'elle veut dire on
reviendra sur vos qualités masculines
vous en parlez c'est ça le côté féminin
des vrai qu'on est très attiré parce que
les artistes ont la même sensibilité les
mêmes émotions et c'est vrai qu'on se
reconna
dans l'autre j'imagine que c'est
difficile effectivement il y a deux
egoos face à face quand mê oui parce que
les hommes sont souvent euh euh les
hommes très connus et tout ça sont très
assez égoïstes et assez centrés sur
eux-mêmes et moi j'ai besoin d'un homme
généreux et ça le mien est comme ça il a
été artiste pourtant mais il y a des
exceptions il y a des exceptions donc il
fallait que je trouve quelqu'un de de
tellement particulier que pour moi ça me
semblait impossible vous aussi quand
même quand vous dites l'artiste a besoin
qu'on s'occupe de lui vous aussi on a
j'imagine que vous avvez toujours besoin
qu'on s'occupe de vous ouis mais j'ai
toujours eu l'habitude de faire tout
moi-même en fait et là maintenant j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un qui s'occupe de moi
aussi bien artistiquement que que
personnellement et ça c'est c'est
vraiment le rêve de toute femme
j'imagine d'ailleurs vous dites aussi
parce que vous revenez comme ça sur
toute votre carrière et votre vie vous
dit Johnny conservera toujours dans mon
cœur une place à part mais ils est trop
absent et plutôt un un second enfant
qu'un père oui ça c'est vrai oui ça
c'est vrai mais moi j'avais des des
besoins de maternels et puis que je que
j'ignorais évidemment et c'est vrai que
c'était très touchant mais pour moi il a
il est resté à 20 ans pour moi c'est
c'est l'image des 20 ans encore
maintenant vous voyez comme ça oui oui
oui je reconnais pas le Johnny de mes 20
ans maintenant c'est c'est quelqu'un de
différent forcément oui vous en parlez
de temps en temps ensemble ou vous ne
vous voyez plus non non vous n'échangez
plus rien chacun
de temps à autre mais disons qu'on ne
parle pas de ça et David vous décrit
d'ailleurs vous comme une mpoule très
physique très proche ah oui je suis
assez physique oui je suis je suis une
maman lyonin j'ai besoin de serrer mes
enfants de les embrasser de les cajoler
j'ai besoin de les avoir au téléphone de
d'être avec eux alors vous parliez des
artistes hommes qui avait un côté
féminin et et vous vous octroyez des
qualités aussi masculines c'est toujours
double oui double alors double oui je
suis oui j'ai une certaine autorité oui
je parce que ça vient de mon impatience
en fait j'ai un tempéramament assez
fougueux et et vous dites que c'est
l'amour des donc des hommes de votre
famille votre frère mais aussi votre
père qui vous a construite et que c'est
votre mère qui vous a donné l'autorité
oh ma mère était une une femme
exceptionnelle mes parents tous les deux
d'ailleurs c'est elle qui m'a faite qui
m'a montré la route tout le temps tout
le temps et c'est elle qui me tenait
aussi elle savait pas les tris/arts de
de de ce que je voyais ce que je
pouvais rencontrer sur mon chemin dans
dans dans ce métier sinon elle aurait
pris peur si elle avait su la vérité non
oui oui ça ça c'est sûr mais en fait
c'est c'est cet amour et et l'amour de
mes parents qui m'a vraiment tenu de
façon à à ne pas tomber vraiment ne pas
aller dans dans des excès ravageurs
ouais vous auriez pu ou oua c'estd drog
parce que je suis assez folle je suis
assez
démesuré mais je peux canaliser en
faisant tout ça sur scène c'est ça qui
est bien c'est un vrai un véritable
exutoire vous parliez de vos parents vos
parents sont restés aussi c'est ce quiil
y a de très fort et très joli toujours à
côté de tout au long de votre vie votre
mère en particulier elle était tout le
temps là c'était le pilier vous aviez
besoin qu'elle soit à côté de vous j'ai
toujours
besoin donc elle vous manque j'imagine
c'est difficile de se retrouver
j'imagine maintenant seul chef de
famille maintenant que tout heureusement
que j'ai mes enfants je crois que ça
c'est c'est extrêmement important parce
que je me dis il faut que je grandisse
maintenant il faut que je grandisse vous
êtes encore j'avais le luxe oh oui
j'étais maintenant il faut que je
grandisse vous n'avez pas le sentiment
d'avoir grandi il a fallu la disparition
des parents pour sentir ou oui non je
suis restée très très enfant et donc
j'aimais bien être bébé en fait c'était
vraiment c'était formidable d'être bébé
c'est un état parfait vous diriez que
c'est le meilleur moment de votre vie oh
bah c'est pas mal est-ce que c'est pour
grandir Sylvie que vous avez adopté donc
maintenant il y a 10 ans à peu près
c'est ça ou cette petite fille bulgare
non parce que j'ai besoin de la présence
des enfants j'ai besoin d'être d'avoir
des enfants puis mon fils était grand
était parti et puis bien sûr j'ai des
des petits petite fille un petit garçon
et tout ça mais j'avais besoin d'un
enfant tous les jours parce que quand je
ne les voyais plus j'étais complètement
effondré et puis j'ai besoin de
m'occuper de quelqu'un vrai que ma fille
est un soleil pour moi c'est une grande
source de de joie et de de bienêtre vous
avez les yeux qui brillent quand vous en
parlez et c'était important de d'aller
en Bulgarie oui l'adopter j'imagine
symboliquement mais oui c'était très
important parce que on est lié on est on
est les mêmes le sait ça on a les mêmes
émotions c'est une slave ma fille est-ce
que c'est lorsque vous êtes retourné en
90 en Bulgarie pour la première fois 40
ans après c'est ça 40 ans après que vous
que vous avez décidé cette adoption
c'était j'imagine essentiel de retourner
en Bulgarie oui oui c'était essentiel
mais en même temps
c'était une grande angoisse et donc moi
j'ai je n'ai pas arrêté de pleurer en
fait pendant 12 jours c'est ce que dit
David c'était douloureux cétaits
douloureux lui aussi était extrêmement
bouleversé c'est juste au moment de
l'effondrement du mur de Berlin et il
est vrai que la Bulgarie était à genoux
quoi c'était et vous avez compris des
choses de vous par quand on vient
c'estdire que j'avais l'impression
d'être le symbole de la liberté pour
tous ces gens et ça c'était extrêmement
bouleversant et et ça m'a beaucoup
remué mais en même temps un merveilleux
souvenir parce que je suis très heureuse
d'avoir pu revoir la maison où j'ai
grandi tout ça parce que maintenant
n'existe plus ils l'ont détruite
qu'est-ce qui est remonéit à la surface
en vous c'était de bons souvenir ou ou
de mauvais souvenirs ou la peur la
crainte parce que vous aviez vécu on
n'en a pas parlé mais à cette époque là
quand même un peu la fin oui c'était
cétait c'était la fin le froid mais
évidemment j'avais 8 ans et en fait
j'avais les yeux rivés sur mes parents
j'essayais de lire en eux euh les
réponses parce que je savais que la
situation était grave qu'il ne fallait
pas parler qu'il fallait pas dire qu'on
voulait partir on avait des gens dans
notre appartement qui avaient
réquisitionné tout et même enfant je
meen rendais compte c'est pour ça
j'étais un enfant assez grave après et
mature parce que forcément parce que
j'ai vécu et ça ça ressurgit lorsque
vous êtes reparti làas c'est comme un
couteau qui est venu dans mon cœur c'est
un couteau d'être une jeune maman
puisque vous êtes en même temps une
jeune maman grand-mère et jeune maman ça
ne vous apaaise pas un petit peu si ça
doit calmer un peu les choses oui tout
calme tout est est un élément calment et
stabilisateur avoir des enfants s'en
occuper les aimer devir faire les
devoirs même crier c'est bon c'est bon
tuas pas fait tes devoirs tu c'est tout
ça est est salutaire c'est vrai vous
disiez tout à l'heure j'aimerais rester
enfant oui oui mais je le reste ce
métier est un métier privilégié parce
que justement il vous garde en
permanence et et vous avez le contact
avec justement l'insouciance et la euh
de la l'enfance ça c'est un métier béni
pour ça c'est c'est vrai que quand on
joue quand on chante ou quand on danse
ou on est on est enfant on est enfant le
fait là d'avoir repris ses succès des
années 60 ah oui c'était un vrai bonheur
parce que j'avais besoin justement
j'avais besoin de j'ai commençéis à à
m'étouffer ma maman était extrêmement
malade je savais qu'elle allait partir
et il fallait absolument que je fasse
quelque chose ça faisait des années déjà
que j'étais en arrêt immobile et
terrassé je me disais il faut que je je
survive à ça c'est quelque chose une des
plus grandes douleurs il faut que je
fasse quelque chose de facile c'est vrai
qu'elle vient de s'éteindre il il y a
peu de temps oui donc donc je voulais
faire un il fallait que je chante et
pour et pour cela j'ai j'ai choisi de de
refaire cet album parce que c'est un un
album de reprise de chansons qui a qu'on
a tous aimé des grandes chansons c'était
un projet très léger et très joyeux
j'étais capable de le faire sur place
donc à Los Angeles donc près d'elle
exactement et donc je suis contente de
pouvoir le elle l' entendu oui elle l'
entendu elle a entendu elle adoré et
j'étais elle aimait beaucoup Paris
s'éveille par exemple remets-moi cette
chanson je l'aime beaucoup et et
d'autres aussi elle aim elle les
connaissait toutes évidemment parce
qu'elle aussi c'était sa jeunesse aussi
la nôtre notre adolescence c'était sa
jeunesse et puis et puis
donc c'était un un projet qui m'a qui
m'a décontracté un petit peu qui a
enlevé un peu de poids tout ça envie de
légèreté si j'entends bien légèé et
envie de lumière à nouveau oui c'est ça
vous finissez votre livre en vous parlez
de votre mère et vous dites je donnerai
cher aujourd'hui pour qu'elle me dise
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais encore comme
folie ma fille c'est c'est quoi votre
dernière folie c'est ça ouais c'est ça
elle elle trouvait que mon métier
c'était de la folie mais elle elle elle
me voyait heureuse donc elle savait que
c'était vital pour moi donc la dernière
folie c'est c'est repartir avec ces ces
chansons repartir dans cette époque
ouais oui on m dit tu peux donc jamais
rester tranquille tu ne peux jamais
rester profiter de ta vie mais elle
savait que ma vie c'est c'est c'est tout
est faite de tout donc et de une grande
partie de de chansons aussi et de et de
scène et de de
mouvement merci Syvie d'avoir dépassé
votre timidité naturelle ah oui je vais
mieuxig je me soigne merci beaucoup
merci vous pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche